hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones is
headed into its final two episodes and
after saying how awful pet owners John
and Danny are this next episode teaser
for episode 5 is making me want to call
the Humane Society there's not much
footage to go off of but just enough
clues hinting at why emilia clarke
promised episode 5 would be bigger than
battled Winterfell and in her words
meant oh sorry effort grano is holding
this I'm gonna break down all thirty
seconds of this and spoiler warning in
case I predict anything to accurately
and ruin your life or if I predict
anything that you would have prefered
what the show ends up doing let's get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
okay the teaser okay the teaser opens
with Tyrion and Daenerys at Dragonstone
while it certainly looked like Daenerys
was fixin to jerk Horus after Cersei in
the mountain chopped off from asan days
head those scorpions all over the walls
means she'll have to Shekhar's another
day essentially Jon's plan to siege
King's Landing by land and by sea has
failed or at least stalled like they may
have blocked off the city from the land
but you're on Greyjoy's iron fleet still
has naval superiority allowing the city
to bring in resources from the water if
they need to spin order to tell with
Daenerys but her silver hair appears
longer a bit more unkempt for years she
has tied her hair in an elaborate
Dothraki braid called a hawk which the
Dothraki traditionally never cut unless
they lose in battle perhaps Daenerys his
recent losses have led her to undo her
braid or maybe Masson day was the one to
have always tied that braid for her in
King's Landing Cersei gazes out over the
city reminding us of her smug stare as
baylor burned and how willing this mad
queen might be to let all of these
buildings burn baylor was to the west of
the red keep so I think now Cersei is
looking northward at the arrival of
John's forces on the horizon to the riot
are what look like the ruins of the
dragon pit which is a location of the
summit between these characters last
season and Cersei must feel pretty proud
that she got all these enemies hopes of
just to destroyed them behind Cersei
Qyburn in the mountain creepily linger
in the shadows and the first episode
Qyburn told bran that Cersei had other
plans for the Dragon Queen but I gotta
wonder have we seen the full extent of
those plans deploy you're on an iron
fleet to wait for Daenerys with scorpion
mounted ships at Dragonstone take
captives line the walls of King's
Landing with more scorpions and then
bring in city residents the red cape
uses human shields it's not a bad plan
but I feel like Cersei still must have a
trick up her sleeve I'd be a pillow
upper corset faking a pregnancy maybe
something that she is waiting for the
right moment to reveal as Jon ser Davos
and Tyrion and their combined unsullied
in Dothraki forces line up the golden
company lined the grounds outside the
walls with the archers and the scorpions
the capital is pretty well defended but
still no war elephants on to the second
half
okay a shot of God how this is keeping
in here a shot of Blackwater Bay shows
the iron fleet moored urine on board his
flagship the silence begins to looked as
his men prepares scorpion more on what
urine could be looking at a bit but
overall this the teasers music evokes a
ticking clock sound similar to Hans
Zimmer's score in Dunkirk which was the
story that featured soldiers on his
shoreline and on boats nervously looking
skyward in fear of air raids a quick
shot of the Dragonstone throne room
shows Daenerys on her throne with Tyrion
and someone else standing before her
it's hard to tell but the shorter it
makes them look a bit like Jaime
Lannister I'm guessing that Jaime's
implication to Brienne last episode that
he was leaving to be with Cersei was
actually him planning to kill Cersei
fight in this last war maybe just trying
to lead Brean out of it remember Tyrion
also recently had a fairly treasonous
conversation with Varys in this same
location with Daenerys his promise to
burn Varys alive if he ever conspired
behind her back fresh on everyone's
minds we could be seeing some kind of
trial here next there's a shot of the
golden company marching through the
streets of King's Landing last episode
gave a brief glimpse of their sigil on
the Winterfell map table it's a pike
with a pile of golden skulls
representing the past captains General
of their army but in the middle of this
formation in the back a hooded figure
pushes through them in the opposite
direction
remember Cersei ordered Qyburn to keep
the gates open to all civilians to add
to her meat shields but perhaps someone
like the Hound or Aria or Jaime
Lannister snuck in before the city was
sealed off which would be setting this
assassin loose in this besieged city
after shots of more Lannister soldiers
knocking scorpion we returned to urines
concerned look skyward the shot of the
cloud shows nothing believe me a magic
I'd the crap out of this but Euron's
expression grows grim as a dragon roars
in the distance so let us be late what
could your own be looking at if the
sight of regel and drogon gave him so
much delight last episode why does he
now appear afraid of this approaching
dragon he's got a dragon killing weapon
at his disposal it could be that Euron
just wasn't expecting to see drogon so
soon
since King's Landing is heavily
fortified with anti-aircraft
and now your ons like okay this is
happening now
and maybe his scorpion is being repaired
at this exact moment and that's why he's
worried some have speculated that urine
could be seeing rogue on but drogon is
now wearing armor I know I know it's a
silly mental limit it's like a dog in a
sweater
even though dragon height is supposed to
be super tough and impenetrable the
dragons on the show have been extremely
vulnerable to spear tips and projectiles
so armor could be useful it would have
to be lightweight because they have to
fly in that but depending on how long
the siege goes on for get injury might
have time to Smith something up this
approaching dragon could be carrying
something surprising like wildfire bombs
dropped from a higher altitude out of
range of the scorpions may be unsullied
paratroopers or you know with a dagger
in her mouth some of you have said that
the dragon roars sounds higher pitched
like a younger dragon a different dragon
than drogon
so if regal or Missourians somehow
resurrect I feel like a lot of fans will
be annoyed by that really I feel like
the only thing to worry you're on
greyjoy like this considering his past
confidence to aim his scorpion at any
dragon would be several dragons imagine
a whole squadron totally overwhelming
their ballistas there had been rumors
that Rogan could have laid eggs in
places like the doom of Valyria or that
other dragons could exist in the distant
shadow lands of pesos Emilia Clarke
called this coming battle bigger than
battle Winterfell and that battle
featured three dragons in an aerial
fight so the sight of dozens of dragons
raining fire in King's Landing would be
sufficiently mental comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at da boss it
subscribed a new rock stars on YouTube
and follow our new podcast feed Westeros
weekly for really access to all of our
Game of Thrones coverage thank you for
joining me and what pow pow pow
[Music]